attisées et puis vous avez sur le marché
des appareils plus simples peut-être
avec plus ou moins cher aussi puisque
celui-ci est à 700 francs et qui vous
permet de travailler 8 800 démonstration
donc vous avez des petits ces électrodes
des électrodes ont enlevé la protection
le biceps labs meilleure protection est
vraiment placée sur le biceps voilà à
l'intérieur ensuite moi je vais me
coller des électrodes sur les droits sur
le ventre voilà ici voilà et ensuite
vous devez régler la puissance de votre
appareil et cette contraction le stimuli
va vous faire contracter les muscles
marché passé en moto doit donc pour vous
soucier c'est le bleu et pour moi c'est
le vert elle a pas d'accord moi je ne
sens rien alors vous serez narnia l'esam
normale n'est pas encore mis pour l'asie
alesi est là je vais plus plus puisque
ce qu'ils veulent attirer ces décharges
électriques
mais quand même je vous écoute en main
et l'a poussée à fond on en fait
j'aurais dû vous expliquer avant il a
doté cette année d'un goûter
7 c'est bien expliqué il faut monter
progressivement elle est montée comme la
paresse mais voilà on est monté jusqu'à
5 dès le début hors d'eux déjà ça
commence à faire un grand ménage est
aussi mauvaise et à décharge électrique
et moi aussi j'en refais une petite
décharge les prix bon alors donc en fait
lisez attentivement la bêtise
de façon à bien bien sentir les
contractions fatigué continuer il faut
savoir que ça marche effectivement pour
les femmes qui ne sont pas sportive pour
celles qui viennent d'accoucher qui
veulent commencer doucement
pour un complément un autre sport on
obtient des résultats on obtient pendant
un mois on peut progresser les s'apprête
à être dangereuse
non non non en fait lorsque là on est
vraiment allé au maximum je sais rien on
va où on obtient des résultats
mais c'est limité à moi cirque au bout
d'un mois et bien on va quand même se
tailler la faf et autres chats